j'espère que vous êtes prêts parce
qu'ils vont pas tarder c'est un fusil
n'a jamais vu de fusil parce qu'avant
c'était plutôt moins les flingues et toi
les élus mais bon apparemment tu t'es
aussi mise au flingue j'étais pas au
courant c'est chaud
je vois tout ça la peur
la jalousie
trahissons
de débarrasser l'univers
hall on m'avait dit vous étiez décréta
prétentieux mais c'est pas vrai du tout
brackett quoi jamais un truc dans l'oeil
mais ta ceinture
encore sauver la galaxie
génial
pouvoir augmenter nos tarifs si on
devient sauveteurs de galaxies à plein
temps
ça me choque
parfois tu t'aperçois que la chose que
tu as passé ta vie à chercher
et là depuis toujours à côté de toi par
exemple
[Musique]
vous savez faire c'est vous priez dessus
non on est une famille
mais je suis pas sûr
fait des années que je te cherche et
vous êtes pieds vous je suis ton père
peter
le destin de l'univers repose sur tes
épaules fais ce que tu veux mais surtout
n'appuie pas sur ce bouton
ça ferait immédiatement exploser la
bombe et on mourait tous allez vas-y
répète ce que je ne te dire j'ai fait un
break
non ça c'est le bouton qui risquent de
tous nous tuer recommence ya sa place à
priori oui
il s'appelle
[Musique]
à vous de jouer bande de nazes
tu vénères salle besson
[Musique]
tiens la bande adhésive je vais en
coller sur le bouton de la mort non on
n'a pas de vente à dc c'est pas vrai il
y en a près de carpentras des six
bateaux mis dans ton sac si tel qu'un
peu avant la bande adhésive c'est bien
toi il faut que je me tape tout le
boulot nous fait perdre beaucoup de
temps
c'est très très mauvais signe
quand je touche quelqu'un je ressens
tout ce qu'il ressent toi tu ressens de
l'amour oui oui c'est vrai je ressens un
amour désintéressé pour tout le monde ou
presque en émois sexuels
pas du tout qua non à elle vient de dire
à tout le monde
le bruit secrète doute les secrets oui
on va savoir adam sadiq s il te plait
camilla haute ma parole
ah ah ah ah ah les hameaux tour à moi à
boire